whether it's online banking social
networking cloud computing smart cards
or even just simple email europeans are
increasingly leaving digital traces of
their lives on computers and the
internet in an effort to keep up with
technological developments the european
union is updating legislation aimed at
better protecting the personal data of
the e u--'s 500 million citizens the
current rules date from 1995 and a lot
has happened since then the e use almost
doubled in size and private information
is increasingly being shared across
borders even outside of Europe citizens
are concerned that companies might pass
on their data without permission and
many including a lot of young people are
unaware of privacy policies when they
communicate online the new proposals
will boost the need for consent when
data is processed it will reinforce the
right to be forgotten so that people can
delete data on the Internet breaches
will be referred to a Data Protection
Authority bolstering responsibility and
accountability on top of that EU rules
will apply to companies active in the
European market even if they are based
abroad and the system won't just benefit
people using a single set of rules will
also be good for companies as they will
no longer have to navigate 28 national
systems ultimately it will cut down on
red tape and improve the competitiveness
of European businesses